as many of you know one of the things
that the Trump Republican tax plan did
is cut the corporate tax rate from
thirty five percent to twenty one
percent but as many of you also know and
you would definitely know if you've been
watching or listening to this show for a
while when we want to figure out how
much taxes corporations actually pay the
tax rate is only one sort of factor it's
just one piece of it because there are
so many mechanisms that can be used to
reduce tax liability all the way down to
zero or sometimes even to get tax
rebates from the government which if
you're a corporation usually end up
getting applied against future profit
rather than actually being sent back to
you like a tax refund the way
individuals get when they file taxes and
case in point we already know of at
least twice as many large corporations
as last year who are paying zero in
federal taxes under Donald Trump's new
tax plan for corporations the Institute
on taxation and economic policy has a
new report out and they found that the
number of publicly traded companies that
are paying zero or less in taxes and
I'll talk about the or less in a second
has roughly doubled and some of these
we've heard of because it's made
headlines so Amazon was one that made
headlines Netflix was one that made some
headlines less commonly known Chevron is
another company and there are others in
fact 60 companies that have been
identified that are paying zero or less
in taxes for 2018 under Donald Trump's
new tax plan and as I mentioned they're
not just paying zero these 60 companies
in total that have been identified so
far have secured 4.3 billion dollars in
rebates and again it's not that they get
a check back because that's not how it
works with these corporate rebates they
now are allowed in total to apply those
4.3 billion dollars in rebates to future
taxes on income and that relates to why
this is such an uphill long-term battle
which I will get to in a second here
and as far as the mechanism through
which this is happening it's not so much
that Donald Trump's plan is all adding
loopholes and new mechanisms to avoid
taxes although there are some I mean the
Trump tax plan closed some quote
loopholes but also created some new ones
and new mechanisms as well but when you
start with a 21% corporate tax rate
instead of a 35% corporate tax rate
there's just a lot less tax that you
have to find ways to zero out with
accounting mechanisms to get to zero tax
liability so it allows more companies to
do it in this case at least twice as
many as for the 2017 tax year when the
rate was 35 percent there was just more
tax that you needed to find a way not to
pay now there was a common talking point
from the right which you might say you
know David it sounds like it conflicts
with what you're saying
I hear from the right that the United
States corporate tax rate is one of the
highest in the world and it's true that
35% was on paper a relatively high rate
but again the effective tax rate of
American corporations is very low and
when you lower it to twenty one percent
that that is now definitely not any
longer on the sort of higher end of the
tax rate spectrum and once again
corporations are still just not paying
it they are more easily able to
completely zero out their tax liability
altogether
so this now gets us to fixing the
problem obviously the corporate tax code
needs to be completely changed the
corporate tax code was written by huge
corporations and their lobbyists and the
sort of revolving door of elected
official lobbyists corporate CEO types
to be as advantageous to them as
possible and unfortunately even if today
we change the tax code to fix a lot of
these problems the accumulated rebates
which I told you about that can be used
to offset future earnings and taxes on
earnings are inevitably going to allow a
lot of these corporations to keep paying
zero or almost zero taxes even after we
fix the problem because they've accrue
all of these rebates that can be applied
against future income so breaking news
it's not trickling down as many of you
may have noticed number two as far as
Donald Trump and his campaign promises
disgustingly broken promises right he's
not draining the swamp he's filling the
swamp the tax reform plan is a total
corporate ah cracy which helps his own
businesses as much as it helps many of
those corporations associated with his
cabinet secretaries and other people
that work for him and that lobbyists
industrial complex that donald trump
said he was going to end he's done a few
little things around the edges which he
can sort of claim victory on but big
picture that the status quo has simply
not changed and there it's it's so funny
because we've done all of this talking
about Trump's promises and whether
they're realistic and the new tax plan
and how it affects corporations and what
the next step is going to be in figuring
out how many corporations are allowed to
pay no taxes or not in the end there's
literally nothing new here like it's
just the status quo it's not trickling
down corporations aren't paying taxes
meanwhile as I told you a couple days
ago on the show you have people who go
out to eat figuring out how they can tip
slightly less without look less without
looking cheap because they can't even
afford what what cost of living has
become meanwhile the waitstaff is saying
well no we need those extra tips and you
have the lower and middle class fighting
while the big corporations are getting
billions of dollars in tax rebates that
they can apply to future tax years this
is how the system is designed it's
working exactly as the people in power
have designed it it's working exactly as
anyone who saw through Donald Trump's
promises knew that it was going to
continue working and that's it it's
almost like the news story today should
be hey guys nothing's changed and
corporations are still able to pay no
taxes if they have good enough
accountants and they're taking advantage
of the right mechanisms that's it it's
almost like a non-story that is breaking
today let me know what you think I'm
Twitter at de Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show and we have
just a lot of great stuff planned for
the friday show today glad you're here
one of today's david pakman show
sponsors is east or built who's giving
everybody in our audience 20% off when
you go to East or built comm and use the
promo code Pakman and this part is
awesome they're also giving a portion of
each purchase to Planned Parenthood and
the ACLU if you've been thinking about
starting your own online store or
upgrading the one you have checkout East
store built it's a full-service set of
solutions they offer fully customized
websites for your web store
instructional materials for improving
your web store low cost accounting
services for your web store one web
store created by e store bill was just
recognized by beheading dot-com as one
of the top 25 best web stores of 2019
East store built has team members
specializing in everything from Shopify
to social media marketing they can help
your business establish as an LLC which
is a great way to help protect your
business from fraud and lawsuits their
team of certified public accountants can
take care of all your bookkeeping your
payroll your electronic timekeeping and
provide other accounting consulting
their accounting team is headed up by a
certified management accountant with
experience managing business budgets of
over seventy five million dollars just
go to East store built calm I've put a
link under this video use promo code
Pakman at checkout PA que ma n to get
20% off your entire order of e store
startup products and materials and if
you're interested in their affordable
professional accounting services just
get in touch with them using their
website contact form tell them David
Pakman sent you and you'll get 50% off
your first month of accounting services
when you sign up for a year subscription
and don't forget that they'll give a
portion of all purchases to Planned
Parenthood and the ACLU